well science is a very it's actually
very difficult field because you need
probably above everything else
extraordinary patience and what keeps
you going is discovery and sometimes in
a lifetime you may have one outstanding
discovery Einstein used to say that that
he was unusual and that he had had to
but anyone would have been enough to
have kept him going
most scientists are not in that league
but we all have at some scale things
that were you know really very proud of
if we do if we discover them often
we are looking for them the idea that a
lot of discovery is serendipitous and
accidental is tremendously tremendously
overplayed I think it's much more likely
that one sees something almost in
everyday life
that puzzles you and you carry it around
with you for some period of time and
then you see some way of connecting to
it uh you could say our discoveries in
autism is an example of that at a very
early age I was impressed by this child
and later saw an opportunity and I
struck when the opportunity was there to
satisfy my curiosity so most discovery
is of that type sometimes you see things
that you can't explain and I shouldn't
say sometimes a lot of time you see
things that you can't explain and
sometimes you come up with explanations
that are really exciting and 99% of the
time all those are wrong and there's
really some trivial explanation for the
thing that's gotten you excited early in
my career I used to hate those things
and I used to say you know you know only
a manic-depressive would love living
like this you know you have yeah you see
something it's weird you have a you come
up with some great encompassing idea
that'll explain it's gonna change how
people think and then the next day you
realize that you were really a dumb
nowadays when those things happen I
actually really enjoy them because there
are so few you know real Eureka moments
in one's life that you have to almost
enjoy the fake ones I mean after all
it's if the feeling is just as good so
I've actually gotten to enjoy those
those weird results that we can't
explain
come up with fanciful ideas and then try
to batter them and then you get a double
satisfaction because your end up
destroying the idea and it's satisfying
to destroy the idea almost as much fun
to destroy an idea as to as to create
going